all right Maxim
Maxim where are you from originally
where'd you grow up
I from ages uh from zero to three
um if I'm sure it was older she's three
years old I grew up in
Tula Russia really yes tell me about
your family
um I will have my biological family
um my biological mother Mother Russia
she's very um pretty gorgeous she's
super fun
very classy yeah she's amazing style and
then my biological father
is um you know he uh I guess uh fights
just boxing uh you know being back [__]
right you know you know those feedback
punching whatever
um and then My adoptive family
uh my mother
um adopted mother is
uh she's a PhD she went to a lot of
college uh went through a lot of
schooling
uh and uh
ah whoa is the adopted family what
brought you to the U.S
yes
she um oh she's wearing the education
career field
and then my adopted father
um
he is a banker
Bank as a financial planner what city
did you come to when you came to the U.S
I came to uh Windsor uh a uh
a cow in winter
in what state
ah
in what state Colorado Colorado
with a adopted family
ah
it's a very good uh
they did a really good job raising me um
the kind of like tough love people kind
of kind of people uh you know it doesn't
raise me to be uh like
kind of operating on my own
um
uh
all right ah are you still in contact
with you with either family
yeah I caught up with My adoptive mother
the most
how did I ever out of all blah my
favorite Wall family members
your childhood you you would describe it
how
uh
you know Ava
tough love
what was that a book um I hate you don't
need me
I have not I don't actually write the
book but um
you know my daughter's mother uh brought
brought that up a lot um
okay were you in high school
I did not graduate high school uh I got
my GED in 12th grade
uh halfway through 12th grade I got my
GED uh
and uh yeah drugs came into your life
when
fishing life ah get ready for it
I'm sorry 15 15.
oh
did that change your life
yes you know yes I can't imagine a life
sober
why do you like getting high so much
uh
oh no oh
I can't really become a different person
you know it makes me a lot more
confident when I'm high
is there anything in your childhood that
you're trying to forget about or escape
from uh
no no not necessarily your parents your
adopted parents do you do well yeah why
did your biological parents are very
they're very they're very classy they
have a lot of class why did you repeat
themselves very well you know they're
clean people like
so that's great why did your biological
parents lose you
uh
uh both you know they're pretty I see
they're pretty narcissistic people
this is 100 but you know I don't know
and crystal meth is your has been your
drug since since you were a teenager
yeah
yes uh no not since you're off I picked
up my Christmas I don't mean addiction
um
uh I'll probably uh
oh how about 8 18 18 yeah when was L.A
that's when you came to La yeah where
you've been staying how did you know
uh 22 22. you've been on the streets for
how long
something female uh
this is 18 and a half but
yeah uh
this is each and a half yeah yeah how do
you make money no
I like money through
um like prostitution
yeah
you may you probably make a good Buck
doing that
yeah
days and stuff you know that's what I
said like prostitution of course what
kind of um who kind of Ben pick you up
are they married uh
sometimes yeah
have you been in love before
uh
huh
yeah I
I don't know if not necessarily I don't
think so no not right now
uh
uh no I I was trying to consider
everyone a relationship
you know everyone like I kind of I need
something from them
you know
what are your goals you're still a young
man what would you like to see happen
ah
you know I definitely uh I want to try
to just I want to you know do more
professional like
filming you know maybe maybe for a TV
show or like
uh
a bug company
I mean a magazine
actually doing photos of me and you know
something
they're like promoting uh or uh
a commercial or something you know is
living on the streets rough life for you
ah
have you had bad things happen to you
like
uh
yes it had I had some like pretty bad
sentences but
you know those are wrong you know being
works for her so
I have to run you know uh so I have to
actually be like responsible and mature
what was the last time you slept
ah it is now
Knight 2D2
I'm sorry
this is day two when I'm asleep
uh 19 was sleep I think see it's like 48
hours and no sleep yeah I think so
what's the longest you've gone without
sleep
probably like a week less than a week
six days what happens to you after going
without sleep for oh we're gonna turn
around
I get really tired tired of having a
garage yeah I got really tired and I
crashed
and then you get everything stolen from
you
at that time I really didn't know how
much
yeah and you're you're basically just
existing with what you what we see here
on camera
kind of not at all not necessarily
either I feel like I I have a lot more
now
you know where do you have it
uh
for people who help me out shopping
so you have people holding your stuff
sugar daddies oh I said seeking
Arrangements do you have do you have
some sugar daddies that are regulars
yes yeah
yes
how much money do they pay you typically
the uh you know only 200 uh or drugs
how much 200 they're in drugs or in like
you know helping me out with like a
place to stay shower hang out uh chill
it's nice I don't know
does your
biological mom know where you are
currently the life that you're living
ah yes
what did she think of it
uh
uh I'm sure she's proud of me
for like you know just
staying like strong
there's some weird chat
what's the hardest part of hardest part
of this lifestyle for you
finding a city that's like the best for
me
I'm sorry I didn't see you know kind of
stay in that's like that's the best way
also you know really figuring out what I
needed and like figure out what I need
you know
emotionally what do you go through uh
if you're depressed or have fun
I'm sorry ah
emotionally
a sadness
I'll uh
uh
being sorry
are you ever lonely
no no a lot loneliness
how do you meet
men to uh
to go out with
huh
uh
in person
in person yeah because people will drive
by and see you yeah yeah
what's your biggest fear what do you
worry about at 22 years old living on
the streets
even if you're uh
uh
you know maintaining to see a lifestyle
uh-huh
yeah you're living a very unstable
lifestyle now
I'd say so probably
not what you're
adopted parents had
going on at home
yeah yeah
no I think you know um
I think I think there's a little more
progress
needs to be done on my part you know um
some genuine work I guess you don't like
really good
what would you say is your greatest
strength
ah
strings
um
oh I see you know we we go there for
people
being there for like human relationship
with you know
ah attentive
or
what's your favorite memory from your
from your life
uh
uh my favorite memory uh
probably uh
oh God
huh
uh
I don't know
um five or Twenty
too many uh you know Christian Iran and
Lucas style uh
Katy Perry
dab
where would you like to be in five years
uh
I would like to be uh
in Pacific Palisades
that's a really nice place yeah
Maxim what would you say is the most
important lesson
you've learned in your life
ah
I was maturity would be being
responsible and there's a responsibility
taking responsibility for
you're just not using what you've
learned yet
ah
early 2000s pop hey Siri
Okay Google
play religious pop
[Music]
oh wait
all right Maxim thank you so much for
sharing your story
I wish you lots of luck out here
all right thank you
thank you